frightening moments for passengers
aboard a Skywest jet that caught fire
after landing in Denver this video
you're about to see shows an engine on
the plane in flames yesterday the
aircraft was operating as a United
Express flight all 63 passengers and
crew members were safely evacuated Kris
Van Cleave reports investigators are
still working to find out how the fire
started first responders worked quickly
Sunday afternoon spraying foam to douse
the flames after an engine caught fire
on this crj700 regional jet planes from
here it happened just after the plane
landed at Denver International Airport
around 2:15 after taking off from Aspen
Colorado about a half hour earlier
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
looking at the pictures I saw some fuel
dripping and the bottom of the engine if
that looks like it'll be some sort of a
ruptured fuel line flight 58 69 was a
United Express flight operated by
Skywest airlines with 59 passengers and
four crew members on board they use
stairs to evacuate this aircraft is not
equipped with emergency slides no one
was hurt in a statement Skywest said the
plane experienced engine issues the FAA
says the plane reported a tire on fire
which then spread to the engine cowling
probably a piece of tire acted as a
shrapnel getting thrown into the engine
cowling which is the intake of the
engine and a piece of hot tire caused
the fan blades perhaps to fail and the
engine caught fire the plane has been
taken out of service while the FAA works
to determine the exact cause of the fire
for CBS this morning I'm Chris Van Cleve